I was reviewing movies when I was 25
years old
hard to believe some of the old critics
never even wore a gun a lot of folks
that were YouTube comments find that
hard to believe I always like to hear
about the old critics never missed a
chance to do so can't help but compare
yourself to the old critics can't help
but wonder how they'd operate in these
times with these films there's this
movie papers say it was a film of
passion but the director said there
wasn't any passion to it not in the
sense that we think a passion for
something good he wanted it to be bad a
new kind of bad we've never witnessed
and I don't know what to make of that I
surely don't it's not that I'm afraid of
it but I don't want to push my chips
forward and go and confront something I
don't understand yeah easier I don't
know I didn't answer any of our calls
he's just been sitting here looking at a
movie all right I'll see you guys when
you get the shoot
critic are you okay step out of the car
please
what's that I need you step out of the
car
what is that for hold still please
welcome the fam video we don't know how
we're still around either Oh returning
movie I wasn't what business is it of
yours how the movie was Fredo didn't
mean no well there be something else
I don't know Lulu there's something
wrong is that what you're asking me
something's wrong or if I saw a comedy
so bad it changes your perception of bad
all together you think you've seen every
type of shitty humor gross-out humor or
anti humor epic movie but then one comes
along that's not only bad on purpose but
it elevates bad to a new level you
didn't even know existed a level that
embraces misery to a point that you have
to laugh so I guess it's working doesn't
makes you laugh but it's only make you
laugh because the only other alternative
is to cry you laugh because you have no
choice you laugh because it's destroying
you do that call it come on just call it
I'm gonna call it the movies think of
the only film that can be impressively
bad yet leaves no joy can get a laugh
even though it's not funny can expand
someone to a new level of awful he wants
to escape yet has constantly drawn in by
what type of bad creates a world so
painful that you stay in it because it's
so fascinating
oh well that's Freddy got fingered well
done okay then I'll just put this back
in the shelf well don't put it on the
shelf and where I supposed to put it
anywhere but not on the shelf or else it
gets mixed in with the others and just
becomes another movie
which it is
oh hey you forgot your good name you
didn't forget this day
Tom Green in the early 2000s he became
very popular for his unique brand of
anti humor some called him an attention
desperate hoarder while others called
him everybody called him an attention
desperate whore but his fans didn't seem
to care partaking in shocking stunts
most normal people when do like sucking
a cow's teed humping a dead moose or
marrying two very more only gotten more
popularity to his credit there were
occasional funny bits like following
pizza delivery boys to offer the same
pizza for cheaper demonstrating how to
camouflage yourself by blending into the
audience this was a guy who had some
comprehension of comedy but his favorite
brand of humor was just being shockingly
odd putting things in his mouth things
in his mouth and yeah it was very mouth
based after he starred in a hit film
20th Century Fox gave him a movie to
write direct and star in with very
little interference the only thing they
seemed to put their foot down is that it
couldn't be nc-17 in that will still
shoot an nc-17 film we'll just have to
bribe the MPAA more than usual to not
have it be rated nc-17
it was destroyed by critics failed at
the box office and won several Razzie
Awards of which Tom Crean accepted the
awards even bringing his own red carpet
from day one when we started writing it
said we wanted to win a raspberry awards
so so it's I'm glad my dream has come
true whatever you thought of this guy he
had a plan and he achieved it whatever
it was the film over the years has been
getting a cult following of people
saying it's a unique kind of bad one
never truly seen in cinema a so bad it's
bad and that bad is so bad it's bad and
that bad is so bad it's bad and that bad
is so bad it's good and that good is so
bad it's bad was their actual clever
thought put into how purposefully
terrible this was did it reach a new
level of awful that you can actually
admire the technique of it admire is a
bad word to use but I can think of no
other in my current state of shit home
syndrome let's take a deeper look with
Freddy got fingered x-ray cat you got me
you can't Gabby get a glance at what
John Criswell Lucy now does with this
time as we see our main character named
Gord played by Canada's punishment
leaves his home during the credits to do
some 90s
I think the editor was drunk because you
know he's doing Freddy got fingered but
he left in these weird freeze frames
because you know he's doing Freddy got
fingered who kicks this whole intro show
that Tom Green can skateboard
reinforcing the rumor that he is in fact
do that something no I call it fake news
he meets up with his parents played by
Rip Torn and Julie Hagerty who are
really wishing right now they had
anyone's career that wasn't Rip Torn or
Julie Hagerty I believed in myself
you'd be a good man gord says he's going
to Hollywood to become a famous animator
like Charles Schulz I'm gonna be a
famous animator like Charles Schulz who
was a comic strip artist not an animator
I'm not implying you don't know this I'm
applying time Green doesn't know this
and we see this dialogue is so
repetitive it's borderline funny in fact
you can measure the amount of laughter
it almost gets by how many times they
say the word proud you make your daddy
proud
your hair me I'm gonna make you proud
daddy you're gonna make you so proud
make your daddy proud you're gonna be so
proud proud yep see that was close but
then it continued to exist on his way
there he sees a horse dick streams pulls
over and jerks it off life has given me
that sentence to report to you there's
no reason for why he pulled over
screamed and touched that horse and it
never comes back into the movie again
I've never been so happy to have a scene
not explained to me he makes it to
radioactive animation or as the rest of
the world calls it Sony studios but he
first gets a job at a cheese sandwich
factory where he does this
[Music]
how would you like to put that on your
resume I was the woman who got slapped
by Tom Green salami dick you deserve an
Oscar just for being near him he sneaks
into the studio where a secretary played
by Drew Barrymore talks to him which is
impressive because the film is now
presenting four to five failed career
choices in one continuous shot you're
just suddenly reminded of all the wrong
things these two actors did in their
lifetimes his wife is dead
he tells cousin it that he's there to
tell one of the head honchos that his
wife is dead as well as informed them
that the color corrector is dyed seeing
how these two shots clearly don't match
up I guess you could argue this
brightness contrast and green tint is
part of the purposefully bad filmmaking
even though it doesn't happen anywhere
else in the film but I like to think
they're in the matrix and Morpheus is
going to erase the glitch that is Tom
Green what if I told you you're annoying
as balls
[Music]
hey I think this is how they divorced
definitely how they divorced he finds
the head of the studio played by Anthony
Michael Hall who slowly realizing weird
science might be the most normal thing
he's ever been in my name is Gord I kind
of want to meet you to show you my
drawings your drawings to make things
stranger I swear there's a heavier
version of hall sitting directly behind
him it's like a yin and yang of the
breakfast club even down to wearing the
exact same suit but with black and white
shirts which is also ironic because you
both look like you're auditioning for
Cobra Kai I'm noting this film is dumb
enough to do that I'm saying this film
it's not smart enough to be that dumb
okay so let me get this right you want
to just barge into a restaurant dressed
like a fucking English Bobby and expect
someone to give you a TV show why not
it's how I got this movie Paul tells him
that while the drawings are good nothing
funny is happening and he needs to flesh
out the characters more to make
something of worth this is literally
before he goes back home and we find out
more about the characters that are going
to be in most of the movie what you need
here is elevation okay there actually
has to be something that happens that's
actually funny I hate to say it but that
can't be a coincidence that must have
taken thought I'm trying to be a piece
of advice because they could dig these
animals out
you gotta figure them out you gotta get
inside the animals gotta get inside the
animals inside the animals well dicks I
wonder where this is going yeah I'll
give it this it could be funny if he's
approached by Nicholas Cage in a bear
suit who punches him to the ground we
all know Cage will do anything he'll
probably do it twice after dressing up
in the deers dead skin he's hit by a
truck that quite frankly I want to see
again why couldn't the editor choose to
freeze that scene one more time so he
goes back home the animation plot
doesn't really come back except for a
few minutes at the end and most of the
movie is just him with his family I'd
say how random but if weirdly enough
feels very planned out in fact in
another bizarre twist his best friend is
played by Harlan Williams for those who
don't know this is one of the most
surreal zania stand-ups you could
imagine
when you want things to get weird you
always have him show up every timber
shark the dark floor Katti dark from
your butt cheeks up to the side of your
face
yeah he cast him as the straight man the
common sense guy who tries to be
reasonable - greens crazy antics do you
think it's kind of dark Gordon gotta
work tomorrow huh you see this is more
than just one giant middle finger this
is a giant middle finger made up of tiny
little middle fingers that compose the
entire thing it's a middle finger on so
many levels I do hope it up holds rip
torrents contract of any time he's in a
movie he has to scream gibberish
well I think the live-action Lion King
found their first note for circle of
life
it will evoke tears look his friend hurt
his leg
we need an idiot to put his tongue on it
Tom do you know of anyone that could
help cameras were turned on for this he
visits his friend in the hospital where
we come across the only consistently
funny character Betty played by Marisa :
hospitals people and who knows people
here died of cancer okay so it is
possible to make Tom Green's writing
funny good to know and I'm the two kids
from Bojack pretending to be an adult
surprisingly I've made a good career out
of it he hits it off with her and they
scheduled a date as he visits his friend
who's next to a woman giving birth oh
the possibilities are 108 okay I'm a
doctor
[Music]
did you know the original title for this
was the audience got fisted after biting
the umbilical cord with his teeth
because at this point I'd be shocked if
he didn't do that he swings the baby
around to wake it up and quite literally
with no segue it's an emotional moment I
mean it no segue watch it's actually so
jarring how much the two don't go
together and how much it has nothing to
do with anything in the film
I thought about laughing and then I
whipped myself whipping myself felt
better
speaking of wit Gord goes to Betty's
place where he discovers she gets
incredibly turned on when she's hit with
a bamboo stick to the one person whose
fetish is finally being lived out
congratulations to the rest of us what
the shit is going on he also discovers
that she wants to be a rocket scientist
so she can have a rocket power her chair
no I mean you tried to make the rocket
wheelchair work but it doesn't work that
must make you feel like a stupid dummy
right don't try to be charming now Tom
green you're so naturally likable he
accidentally hits her in the face though
which means he's earned a blow job I'm
gonna give you a blow job I think this
is how most Tom Green fans think dating
works she discovers though that he still
has his umbilical cord it's taped it's
just for fun I taped it there for fun I
can't think of any possible way to make
that funny so I'm just gonna continue
with the story I started before hey
critic are you here you weren't at the
studio are we still shooting today
yeah I've got my costume and everything
Oh Malcolm let's go to my room
[Music]
you don't have to do this I could just
go home let me ask you this if a film is
meant to be so bad that nobody would
like it then what is the purpose of the
film if people like it is it a failure
if it's hated by everyone or failure if
it's enjoyed by a select few even some
well-known names do you have any idea
how crazy you are
you mean the nature of this movie I mean
the nature of you did you ever think how
much thought would go into making the
absolute worst thing ever if you believe
that some philosophers do the complete
perfection is hell then what's the
opposite what's heaven
nothing but flaws oh my god are you one
of those assholes the defense Freddy got
fingered
oh really hurt a lot hello
yes is Malcolm there not in the sense
that you mean critic what's going on
where's Malcolm you need to come see me
are we shooting stay or what you know
how this is gonna turn out don't you
what the hell are you talking about
line from no country for old men look
just stay there I'm gonna come and shoot
okay oh by the way how was the movie
what is the Mafia
you
so after core gets as much earned BJ he
decides to take a shower back at home in
a scuba suit Turin escapes this realm of
man this squeezing past the camera that
even leaves a shadow on him another
glitch in the matrix lord knows I could
use an exploding Hugo Weaving at this
point he talks with his brother Freddy
who works at a bank and constantly tells
Gord he needs to grow up so cross your
fingers and hope that I get a job I'm
serious
all right fingers crossed I hope I get
to draw be I got my fingers I got my
fingers crossed
oh I get it this movie sucks I'm
actually wondering if there was an Oscar
caliber film about a dysfunctional
family who has to deal with their son
who was addicted to drugs they just
forgot to put the drugs part in this
would be a dramatic powerhouse if he was
on crystal meth did you get a job I got
a job and I wanted to surprise you he
lies to both his father and Betty that
he got a job and Betty takes him out to
celebrate
oh I know this place it's the same
upscale restaurant that doesn't allow
mr. bean the three stooges Ace Ventura
the Marx Brothers Charlie Chaplin Benny
Hill or on hardy Jerry Lewis or the Tiny
Toons in I believe it's called fine
how-do-you-do again though just listen
to this dialogue and tell me they're not
aware if not mocking this exact set up
would you like a piece of cake for
dessert I really love a piece of cake
daddy of course you can have a piece of
cake your birthday yay I'm honestly
shocked the restaurant dialog isn't just
replaced with this most Orthodox master
for dots most orthodontists deal with
about smelt or got it is your job really
Carter I mean I have grass I have some
grafts I can show you if you pay
attention to these patterns here you can
see on the graphs I think we're
witnessing the pitch for the movie here
why would this do well grass just grass
you're fired you're fucking fired Bob
Bob
you know he seems like an unsuccessful
Gruber brother Hans Simon and Gord more
focused on terrorism of comedy if you
laugh he shoots you gourds father sees
he lied though and calls him out on it
wait a minute you're crippled yeah don't
you know it's offensive to use that word
now this shit
klas big surprise they trash the place
and are told to stop because it's a
fancy restaurant no really those are the
exact words it's kinda like saying don't
trash the Taj Mahal it's hmm
Betty bails and now which is kind of
funny thing the parents just left him
there in jail and she says he should
have just told her the truth at home I
wouldn't have cared even though that
means I'm a loser just because you're
not a stockbroker doesn't mean you're a
loser being Tom Green is because you're
a loser
oh here's an important fact Oh ear pop
pop that was written into the movie
somebody said it was essential for those
words to go in that moment she advises
him to relax by eating playing music and
drawing so you get this remix of
nightmares that you've had for the past
couple weeks fun fact this is a dark
ride at Disneyland ninth level of hell
okay so this is gonna sound strange but
listen to this line if this were
Pakistan you would have been I want you
to remember he said that line because
believe it or not there is a weird-ass
way it comes back into the story don't
guess how you can't know really don't
you can just that you can't so his best
friend says that his father really you
can't give up so his best friend says
his father really seems like a character
and he should focus more on him and
that's exactly what the movie suddenly
does there's a lot more focus on the
father and his connection with Gord for
a long time I think in Academy
award-nominated script Oh someone some
royalties his father runs over a
skateboard ramp as once again it goes
from Crazy Taxi music to emotional music
in the length of a bedbugs distro we
shouldn't put up with a way
if I were you I wouldn't stand for
[Music]
Greeks you will believe God hates you
and wants you to know it we cut to a
scene where there at a family
psychiatrist but honestly I think this
scene exists just to have Tom Green as
Sigmund Freud in the same frame because
let's face it that opportunity will
never happen again well at least I don't
touch Freddie everyone he fingers him
yeah I guess we're almost two-thirds
done with the movie might as well have
some reference to the title I'm required
by law to notify the authorities
humanity was a mistake
we think up the Freddy watching
someone's insights get ripped out of him
by suppose and professionals again that
can't be a coincidence the doctor comes
to take Freddy away despite him denying
that his dad ever touched him it's not
your fault your dad finger gee what are
you talking about my dad doesn't finger
me come on son we'll take you out of the
music almost sounded disappointed that
he wasn't fingered hell with this film
maybe what's supposed to be he's taken
away and his father gets drunk claiming
he didn't do anything sexually wrong
while doing something sexually wrong
well I can cross that off my bucket list
seeing Rip Torn snake adass and
regretting it I was very drunk when I
made that list gourd decides to give up
on his dreams as Betty continues to work
on her rocket power chair and let me
guess gourd comes to be a jackass shut
up Betty
shut up can't you see we're both just a
couple of stupid idiots
good Gordie look lady I know you're a
crazy horny obsessive emotionally
denying masochistic nymphomaniac but you
can still do better than Tom Green you
see anybody we then cut to Freddie in
the Institute for sexually molested
children where he's surrounded by
out-of-control kids listening to creepy
music and watching Texas Chainsaw
Massacre you got things
no okay
[Music]
I wasn't here for a second was I that
scene actually took me someplace else
a place not of this realm it was not a
good place in fact it was a very very
bad place one of the worst places I've
ever been but it was so bad I almost
want to go back to it I want to study it
I want to understand how on every level
of unpleasantness this scene went above
and beyond what I thought possible in a
film James Gunn was fired for tweeting
scenes like this and this guy was given
14 million dollars to bring it to the
big screen I have never witnessed a
scene like that in cinema and only this
story and this tone could build up to
something so heinous there is no place
you can look no area you can escape to
nothing else you can think about except
every possible ugliness crammed into
this one moment you saw it didn't you
I can't unsee it that's why you're
standing there aren't you
it's deaf writing Alan calling the
police like what that woman should have
done no country for old men who totally
don't get why she didn't do that he was
really far away she had plenty of time
to get out of there but this scene this
scene is even more terrifying
sit
you don't have to view this people
always say the same thing what do they
say they say you don't have to view this
you don't I need to understand what
can't be understood which shouldn't be
understood so call it are you watching
the rest of the movie with me were you
taking the other way out I knew you were
crazy when I saw you watching that movie
call it no I ain't calling it call it
the movie doesn't have any say it's you
you decide what has worth it or doesn't
call it
by the way I totally killed her
so after every terrible thing you can
imagine is put on screen we didn't cut
to Leave It to Beaver leave it to beaver
they even cut back to it twice after
that scene Leave It to Beaver I don't
know what they're doing but I know
they're D'Arnot gourds mother leaves the
movie because oh Jesus she needs a
reason oh yeah there's a running joke
that this kid always gets hurt I guess I
was too busy mentioning the other child
abuse to bring up that child abuse life
choices
Gort sees that Betty accomplished her
dreams though which gives him
inspiration to accomplish his bringing
his story about a zebra sent our family
to the studio half the time instead Yeah
right sure I saw a guy get half man half
zebra mutant he's a he's a myth the myth
it's a myth it's like a Greek myth
interesting note this page at the script
wasn't written so they just improvised
the whole thing she's like a Greek
African African kid American Greek myth
I'm amazed how much it shows to his dad
follows him in taking out Barrymore in
his anger well it's more kind in the
other version they shot
his father tears up the place which of
course convinces the producer to write a
check I have never seen a more creative
or exciting pitch than that I wasn't
even thinking about writing a check
today I'm completely comfortable
green-lighting this I think we just saw
how most Adult Swim shows are made yep
definitely a documentary on Adult Swim
show creators he makes the show grabs a
helicopter and confesses his love to
Betty I think because he felt big things
had to happen at the end even though
there's no reason no I'm not mocking the
film I really think that's the mindset
I'm giving into the Stockholm
and so is she clearly he then takes the
majority of his budget money and spends
it all on one big stunt acknowledging he
totally wasted his big opportunity then
the other $750,000 that's all my money
that's all my money gone no easy come
easy go
it's where it's so where it's like
watching Caesar this dumb animal
becoming more and more conscious but not
wanting to let anyone catch on you damn
dirty ape what do you want - so you
remember that line the father had from
earlier if this were Pakistan you would
have been well Gore took part of his
house with his father in it - Pakistan
now you might be wondering what's the
connection outside of the father just
say the word Pakistan once I have no
idea but he did say it and I'm reporting
on it please send your fan theories to
this address and never breed he couldn't
even Center the one week later caption
in any other film I'd say that's a
mistake but I don't think it is here I
think he did it on purpose just to make
everything in this goddamn film a little
off you know he'd do it you know that's
what happened so after he sprays his
father with elephant jizz this film
really is too predictable
they finally seemed to patch things up
what the hell it is they're patching up
I have no idea man you want me to be but
I'm your son
don't want you to be proud oh it's the
heart of a film in that he's probably
gonna eat the heart of a cow or
something but they're captured and held
hostage causing a worldwide movement of
people and news organizations demanding
to let them go even his mother and new
lover Shaquille O'Neal are concerned I
did all this for you
nipples pierced can you do it like this
that horrible moment you realize you can
go lower than Kazaam so Howard Gordon is
father gonna get out of this it's not
really made clear the movie just says
they were freed and everyone is on the
runway ready to greet him
just when you're wondering when this
movie is going to end so is the movie
that's really a sign someone is holding
as they return you know this would be
really good if it was good but the kid
who runs after them and gets chopped up
by the propeller crying that he's still
okay
well of course it would end there I
wouldn't imagine anything less because I
actually can't imagine anything less
they then show all the scenes that
weren't good enough for the movie I as
well was shocked such a concept exists
and let's give credit that the final
thing said is the exact perfect line to
end this film I think that's the most
poignant question you could ask this
movie but I will say I did ask it it is
hard to find words to describe the
impact this film has left it is clearly
bad and it is intended to be bad
probably aiming to be the baddest thing
humanly possible it's too self-aware to
just be run-of-the-mill dumb but the
level of insulting idiocy is so grand
you could call it ahead of its time in
terms of troll humor possibly even the
greatest troll movie ever made it's like
the film wants to be a regular bad
comedy but it's too dumb to know how to
do it and it glorifies the hell out of
knowing that it achieves exactly what
it's looking for pissing off everyone in
the stupidest of ways and my inner
troublemaker has a strange respect for
that it's the Barton think of bad films
I don't always know the intent behind
the madness but I've convinced the
filmmakers no I have never come across a
movie like this in my life
I hate everything about it for the exact
same reasons I love everything about it
and this is a whole new phenomenon that
comes from him him you know I had a
dream the other night there were two
pits one was filled with the most
delicious caviar the world has ever
known
and the other was filled with shit Tom
Green showed up in the carcass of a dead
deer and he dived into that pile of shit
he dug so deep into it that he actually
found a little bit of caviar then mixed
in with the shit none of us wanted to
try it but he forced it
the combination created a brand new
flavor never tasted by anyone it was the
most unique tasting thing anyone had
ever put their mouths
it was beyond description Tom Green
winked and said there's plenty more
where that came from but you can only
find it in the shit
I walked up on the edge of that pit
stared out or the biggest pile of shit
I've ever seen in my life I bent over I
took one big breath and then I woke up
for those of you who think I killed my
entire cast for this movie I did kill
Rob Lowe you owe me $2
[Music]
[Applause]
you
hey the blocker here doing the charity
shout-out in this week we are doing the
Fisher House Foundation the Fisher House
Foundation builds comfort homes where
military and veteran families can stay
free of charge while loved one is in the
hospital these homes are located at
military and medical centers around the
world they have up to 21 suites with
private bedrooms and baths with families
sharing a common kitchen laundry
facilities a dining room and living room
since its inception the program has
saved military and veteran families an
estimated four hundred seven million
dollars in out-of-pocket costs for
lodging and transportation the Fisher
House Foundation also operates the hero
miles program using donated frequent
flyer miles to bring family members to
the bedside of injured servicemembers
they also use the hotels for Heroes
program as well using donated Hotel
points to allow family members to stay
at hotels near medical centers without
charge so even if you don't have much
money to give you can also donate flyer
miles and/or Hotel points as well if you
look at their site in their YouTube
channel you can see more than 30,000
families in 2017 alone were helped by
this wonderful organization these people
have sacrificed so much and they're
asking you to sacrifice so little click
on the link and see how you can make so
many strong families even stronger
[Music]
you